Transcriber: Rawda Mohamed
Gözden geçirme: Gökçe Nur Pulat
Özge ben. Çok iyi insan boklarım.
Şöyle anlatayım.
Bundan 10 12 sene önce bir
spor salonuna üyeyim.
Kondisyon bisikletinde vakit
geçirmeyi çok seviyorum.
Bir hoca gelecek dediler, bir sınıf,
on beş tane bisiklet.
Hepimiz orda bir spinning dersi yapacağız.
Bu spinning dersine büyük bir
hevesle rezervasyon yaptım.
Gittim. İşten çıkmışım, yorgunum, bir
köşedeyim, en arkada bir yerlerde
ders başladı.
Pedalları çeviriyorum
derken derken hocanın
yanında böyle bir tane kadın
gözüme çarpmaya başlıyor.
Kadın böyle pür makyaj gelmiş,
saçlar fönlü falan.
Beni ancak bir düğünde filan
öyle görebilirsiniz.
O spinninge o halde gelmiş.
saçlarını o tarafa atıyor,
biraz pedal çeviriyor,
bir bu tarafa atıyor, biraz
daha pedal çeviriyor.
Küçücük bir kıyafetler var üstünde,
kendini seyrediyor.
Dersi yaparken pedal çeviriyor.
Çok beğeniyor, gördüğünden memnun.
Ben böyle “Allah’ım nereye düştük
ya rabbim?!” diyorum.
Bunu benim yalnız başımayken
bile yapmam mümkün değil
derken derken poposunu
filan izlemeye başlıyor.
Ondan da çok memnun.
Bir ders, iki ders.
Sonra anlıyoruz ki hocayla arasında
böyle bir hafif bir flört var.
Bu yaptıkları benim gıcık
olduğum bütün hareketler
onun adamın dikkatini
de çekmesini sağlıyor.
Ben iyice köpürüyorum,
bir ders daha olacak,
giderken söylendiğimi fark ediyorum.
Diyorum lanet olsun, gideceğiz şimdi
yine bu kadını izleyip duracağız.
Herkesin dikkatini çekecek.
Lanet olsun, ne kadar kötü, pis, tuhaf
bir insan yani olacak bir şey değil.
Sarıyorum bir 10 sene öncesine,
üniversiteye yeni başlamışım.
Psikoloji bölümündeyiz ODTÜ’de
ön sırada bir tane oğlan
dikkatimi çekiyor.
Oğlan elini kaldırıyor sürekli.
Her derste, hiç fark etmiyor konu.
“Hocam, bir şey söylemek istiyorum.
Hocam, bu söylediğiniz ile ilgili benim
söyleyecek bir şeylerim var.”.
Artık böyle sıtkım
sıyrılıyor bu nedir böyle diye
derken derken işte intihar
konusunu işliyoruz sınıfta.
Tekrar bunun eli havada,
en önde ben böyle “hasbinallah” filan.
- Hocam
+ Efendim?
- Ben Finlandiya’daki ve Türkiye’deki
intihar oranlarını karşılaştırdım.
+ Ee evladım?
- Bir tane rapor yazdım,
onu sizin kapınızdan attım.
Bir de cüretkar, diyor ki okur musunuz?
Ben bildiğimi söylemekten
çekiniyorum yani elimi kaldırıp.
Arkada bir yerde izliyorum
bütün bu olanları.
Tabii herkes onun adını öğrenmiş filan.
İyice sinirlerim bozuluyor.
Diyorum ne kadar böyle ilgi delisi, ukala,
bilmiş bir şey bu lanet gelsin.
İnşallah bir daha aldığım
derste bulunmaz yani bu oğlan.
Sonra Yıldız Tilbe'nin bir
sesi var biliyorsunuz.
Hiç birinizi sevmiyorum ama
yanınızda çok sıkılıyorum.
Milleti boklayacak birine ihtiyacım var.
Bir kızla tanışıyoruz, böyle
görüyoruz birbirimizi.
Göz göze geliyoruz ve o anda buluşuyoruz.
Ondan sonra bir daha
yollarımız ayrılmıyor hiç.
Oturuyoruz kantinde, çimlerde, çarşıda
kimi görürsek
“Ayy saç bu renge boyatılır mıymış?
Bu kıyafetle derse gelinir miymiş?
Böyle ulu orta öpüşülür müymüş?
Ay bu çocukla “date” edebilir
miymiş?” filan filan.
Okul hayatımız böyle geçiyor.
Sarıyorum 3 4 sene öncesine.
Artık lisedeyim.
Bir öğrenci değişim
programıyla Amerika’ya gitmişim.
Sınıfta ilk günüm,
kulaklıkları takıyorum, arka
koltuğa oturuyorum,
herkesi görebileceğim bir açıya.
Bilin bakalım orada da ne yapıyorum?
Bütün bunlar yaz tatilinden
geri gelmişler.
Biri diyor ki “İşte ben çok sörf yaptım,
harika da bir yaz geçirdim.”
Biri diyor ki “Ben işte 10
tane çocukla tanıştım.”
Ondan sonra, “Hepsiyle flört ettim.”
Bir şakalaşıyorlar.
“Ben ne kadar boş insanların arasındayım.
Yani bunlarla arkadaşlık edeceğim ben.
Yani lütfen.. olamaz böyle bir şey.”
İnsan biraz okula geliyorsa değil mi?
Bir ilgisi, bir şey olur,
bir ağırlığı olur.
Ders yapmaya gelmişsin herhalde orada
öyle.
Daha geriye sarıyorum.
4 yaşındayım.
Kardeşim dünyaya gelmiş.
Bir bebek... Gülüyor.
Evdekiler: Oy güldü!
Peşindeler.
Ağlıyor, “Eyvah çocuğum neyin var?”
herkes başında.
Bir süredir bu ilgiyi ben görmüyorum evde.
Görünmez oldum neredeyse
o doğduktan sonra.
En sonunda kaka yapıyor.
Annem başına geliyor
“Ah bokunu yerim senin.”
Aha diyorum bir fikir.
Bunu yapabilirim.
Gerçekten beni de görürler böylece.
Kaka yapıyorum altıma.
Böyle geniş.
Yüzümde bir gülümseme.
Gidiyorum annemin yanına.
“Anne” diyorum. “Kaka yaptım.”
Zannediyorum ki “Aa,
bokunu yerim senin de.” diyecek
ve ondan sonra ben
istediğim ilgiyi göreceğim.
İki dakika sonra bir leğenin
başındayım.
Neden? Çünkü ablaymışım ben.
Ve artık altıma yapmamam gerekiyor
ve bunu da asla unutmamam gerekiyor.
O yüzden kirli çamaşırlarımı o küçücük
boyumla deterjanlı suyun içinde
çitilemeye başlıyorum.
İnanılmaz utanıyorum,
olduğum her halden,
bulunduğum yerden,
gördüğüm muameleden... Bir şeyler yanlış.
O yapabiliyor, ben yapamıyorum.
Yani o ilgiyi görüyor, ben göremiyorum.
Herhalde yanlış bir şeyleri yanlış
yöntemlerle istiyorum.
Ya da ona verilip bana verilmiyorsa
bende bir tuhaflık var.
Kötü bir an.
Bir daha da asla o leğenin başına
dönmek istemiyorum.
Bu hikayelerin hepsini bir tarafa koyalım.
Doktorayı bitirdiğim sene tesadüfi olarak
Geştalt terapi ekolü ile tanıştım
ve çok sevdim.
Ve öyle düşünüyorum ki buna sadece
bir terapi ekolü demek haksızlık.
Çünkü insanla ilgili olan her alanda
çok önemli etkileri var.
Mimariden sanata,
eğitimden politikaya, reklamcılığa...
Bütün insanın olduğu her yerde
çok kucaklayıcı, varoluşçu, bütüne bakan,
kavramaya yönelik bir yaklaşım.
Beni de sıcacık kucakladı.
Tamamlanmamış işler kavramını ilk Geştalt
ekolü ile tanıştığımda öğrendim.
Bu ekolün psikoterapi literatürüne
en büyük katkısı bu kavram.
Şöyle ki beynimiz...
bir bütünü algılamaya eğilimlidir.
Bu bütünün bazı parçaları eksikse,
biz onları kafamızda tamamlarız
ve o bütünü oluştururuz.
Ben size farklı açılarda
üç tane nokta verirsem,
siz onların arasına birer çizgi çizersiniz
ve bir üçgen gördüğünüzü söylersiniz.
Bu fenomenin ilişkilerdeki karşılığını
araştırmak için
Zigarnik 1900′lerin
başında bir çalışma yaptı.
Çalışmasında garsonları kullandı ve şu
araştırma sorusunu sordu.
“Bir ilişkide, garson
ve müşteri ilişkisinde.
Acaba garsonlar çok bahşiş bırakan
müşteriyi mi daha çok hatırlıyorlar?
Yoksa hiç bahşiş bırakmayan
müşteriyi mi hatırlıyorlar?”
Bence bu sorunun cevabı çok basit.
En çok bahşişi kim
bırakırsa onu hatırlıyorlar.
En azından ben öyle umuyorum.
Hatta şöyle de karşılıyorlar
bir dahaki sefere.
“Özge Hanımcım hoş geldiniz.
Her zamanki masanızı sizin için ayırttık.
Ne yemek istersiniz?
Biz hemen ilgilenelim.
Ben hatırlıyorum geçen sefer ne yediğinizi
isterseniz hemen onları hatırlatayım.
Hazırlatayım sizin için.”
Ama çok öyle olmuyor.
Araştırmanın sonuçları gösteriyor ki
bu garsonlar aslında ilişkinin
tamamlanmadığı müşterileri daha çok
hatırlama eğiliminde oluyorlar.
Bir düşünsenize, siz bir garsonsunuz.
bir müşteri gelmiş, ilgileniyorsunuz,
güleryüzle karşıladınız,
bütün servisi yaptınız,
çıkabilecek bütün sorunları
mutfakla irtibatı en kısa süreci
sağlayarak çözdünüz.
Her şey tıkır tıkır gitti.
Keyif aldığından emin oldunuz
ve ona gülerek uğurladınız
ve takdiriniz gelmedi.
Tamamlanmamış bir şey var orada,
nasıl bunu anlamlandırmak
ihtiyacında oluruz.
Bir boşluk varsa biz bu boşluğu doldurmak
Ve oturur bunu düşünürüz.
Niye bu adam vermedi?
Ben nerede hata yaptım?
Onda ne tuhaflık vardı ?
Niye bu böyle oldu?
Sizin ilişkilerinizde de
vardır böyle şeyler.
Süpermarketin birinde birisiyle kavga
edersiniz,
gelirsiniz yatağınıza yatarsınız
gece yastığa başınızı koyarsınız
ve dersiniz ki “Şunu diyecektim ve ona
haddini bildirecektirim, diyemedim ya.”
Diyemedim.
Bir gün, iki gün sizi meşgul eder bu.
Yetmez, birkaç hafta
sonu rüyanıza girer.
Bu tamamlanmamış şey.
Ailenizde vardır böyle konuşmalar.
Duyarsınız.
Senin annen 20 sene önce bana şunu
yapmıştı, terbiyemden sustum.
Şimdi olsa neler neler söylerim ben ona.
Ya da 20 senedir bunlarla ilgili
bir şey yapıyorum,
bir kere takdir etmedin beni yahu.
Dikkat çekici bir şeyi var burada.
Hepsinde bir ihtiyaç açık kalmış.
Yani tamamlanmamış şey bir
ihtiyacın açık kalmış.
Ne mi? Garsonun takdir
ihtiyacı açık kalmış.
Öbürünün kendini savunmaya
Bir ikinin duymak istediği bir laf var,
duymak istediği laf,
belki güzel bir eşlik açık kalmış.
Bir ihtiyaç açık kaldığında,
farklı bir örüntü de biz oluştururuz.
Dönelim benim kaka deneyimime.
Görülmek istiyorum.
Değil mi?
İhtiyacım, psikolojik ihtiyacım, görülmek,
görülmek istiyorum.
Etrafımı izliyorum.
İşe yaradığından emin
olduğum bir yöntem seçiyorum.
Uyguluyorum.
Doyasıya, gönlümce görülmek yerine,
çok utanacağım bir şeyle karşılaşıyorum.
Dolayısıyla burada ben
bazı çıkarımlarda bulunuyorum,
bir çocuk olarak, “Özge, görülmek mi?
Şöyle bir kenarda dursun,
sen bunu yapacağına görülmek istediğinde
kenara çekil, bekle.
Başkası kendini göstermek istediğinde
onların bu ihtiyacına da kayıtsız kal.
Çünkü seninkine böyle yapıldı.
Hatta sinirlerine de bilirsin
onlar görülmek istediğinde.
Çünkü sana sinirlendiler.”
Tabii ki bu yöntemlerin hiçbir tanesi
önümdeki hayatımda benim
bu ihtiyacı karşılamama yetmez.
Benim o gün o leğenin başında
yaptığım hayat tasarımı
benim bu ihtiyacımın daha
da açık kalmasına sebep olur.
Bir ihtiyaç, ne kadar
uzun süre karşılanmazsa
o kadar uzun süre...
benim için önemli olur.
Her gün daha da önemli olur,
her gün daha da önemli olur.
Benim derdim gücüm görülmek olur.
Her şeyi bunun üstünden görürüm.
Bazı sorular alıyorum.
Arada sırada, diyorlar ki “Özge Hanım,”
“Ee?“, “Ben hayatta ne yapmak istediğimi
hiç bilmiyorum.
Bilsem hemen uygulamaya başlayacağım.
yapmak istediğim şeyleri.”
Niye bu böyle oluyor işte. Bu yüzden.
O tamamlanmamış işin açık kalan
ihtiyacı burnumun önünde
o kadar büyük bir yer kaplıyor ki,
bununla uğraşmaktan ne yapmak istediğimi..
göremiyorum. Göremem de.
Bu nedenle burada küçük bir
temizlik yapmak lazım.
Birkaç tane örnek vermek gerekirse.
Mesela ben sürekli görülmekle uğraştığım
için çalıştığım herhangi bir yerde
mobbinge mi uğruyorum,
haklarım mı verilmiyor,
yalnızlaştırılıyor muyum,
kötü mü zaman geçiriyorum?
Farkına çok zor varırım,
çok zamanımı alır.
Çünkü bunlar değil benim meselem.
Patronum beni gördü mü görmedi mi?
Farkına vardı mı varmadı mı?.
Başka bir şeyle ilgileniyorum.
Bütünde ne olduğunu,
acı çekip çekmediğimi,
ne hissettiğimi bir türlü anlayamam.
Son zamanların çok moda bir terimi
var; toksik ilişkiler.
Toksik bir ilişkinin içinde olup
olmadığımı da anlayamam değil mi?
Adam beni görsün mü görmesin mi
diye uğraşıp duruyorum
ve bu adam beni manipüle mi ediyor?
Ondan sonra yaptığı şeyler
hoşuma mı gitmiyor?
Neyden kurtulmak istiyorum?
Çıkıp ne yapacağım?
Bilemem.
Diyorlar ki “Konfor alanınızdan çıkın,
her şeyinizi değiştirin.”
Bunun da çok mümkün olduğunu düşünmüyorum.
Çünkü bu tamamlanmamış işle
sabitlenen benim örüntüm.
Dışarıdan uygulaması ne kadar zor
görünürse görünsün benim bildiğim tek şey,
aslında neyi biliyorum ben?
Sadece geri çekilmeyi, görülmek
istediğinde geri çekilmeyi.
Birisi kendini göstermek istediğinde
de görmemeyi.
Haliyle bildiğim yer en rahat
ettiğim yer haline gelir.
Benim için en konforlu yerdir.
Kendini göstermenin başka yollarını
öğrenmeden ben nereye gidiyorum?
Oradan çıkıp ne yapacağım?
Leğenin başına geri mi döneceğim?
Tekrar mı utandırılacağım.
Değil mi? Sonra diyorlar ki “Size hizmet
etmeyen şeyleri biraz geride bırakın canım
onlar artık lazım değil hayatınızda,
bırakın geçmişte kalsınlar.”
Ben nasıl bırakayım “Bu hizmet etmiyor.”
dedikleri örüntü veyahut da
insanlarla ilişkimdeki benim halim aslında
gene o leğenin başında yaşadığım utancı
yaşamamak üzere, yani kişisel bütünlüğümü
korumak üzere.
bütün bu şeyi ben uygulamışım ve
silsilesi ne kadar yorucu
olursa olsun bir derdimin peşindeyim,
bir daha oraya geri dönmemek istiyorum.
Asla geride bırakamam.
Ne zaman bırakabilirim?
Orada yeterince kalıp benim için neyin
önemli olduğunu,
kendimi neyden koruduğunu,
aslında hep ne yaptığımı görürsem,
görmeden gidersem gene eskisinin
başka rengine başlamış oluyorum.
Dolayısıyla hayatım bir patinaj
dan ibaret oluyor.
Bu Geştalt çalışmalarını yaptıktan sonra
kendi tamamlanmamış işlerim ile
birazcık mesai şansım oldu.
Görene kadar onların başında kaldım ve
anladıkça bir şeyler değişti.
Ve bir şeyler değiştikçe
kendimi gösterebileceğim
yeni alanlar bulabilmeye başladım.
Bunlardan bir tanesi sosyal medyadır.
2015′te orada yazılar yazmaya başladım.
Bu süreç beni buraya,
sizlerin yanına getirdi
ve sizler de şimdi benim bu görüşmeme
şahitlik ediyorsunuz ve eşlik ediyorsunuz.
Ve hatırlamanızı istiyorum ki gideceğiniz
yerlere çok acele etmemek lazım.
Yeterince kalmadan başka yerlere varılmaz.
Çok teşekkürler.